[Applause]
and finally new rule the washington post
is wrong democracy doesn't die in
darkness
it dies in plain sight because enough
people think democracy is a luxury
america can no longer afford
that is
that is pretty much the position of the
republican party now that you can vote
for anyone you like but it doesn't count
if it's not us
heads we win tells we coup
i know that some people like to say
there's not much difference between the
parties but actually in america 2022
there's more of a difference between the
parties than there ever has been in
american history
really and here's why democrats for all
their flaws still see democracy as the
essence of america they see america and
democracy as inextricably linked they
believe that one without the other is
unthinkable
republicans
thinkable
[Applause]
very very thinkable
republicans now seem to be okay with
america continuing to exist as a country
but without being a democracy
utah senator mike lee says we're not a
democracy democracy isn't the objective
liberty peace and prosperity are we want
the human condition to flourish ranked
democracy can thwart that
which is a weird idea for a campaign ad
vote for mike lee because voting is bad
[Applause]
but beyond that this is a true sea
change
in american politics and mike lee is not
the only one saying it out loud here in
california someone named rachel hamm is
running for secretary of state and she
says i want to make it hard to vote
i want it to be a privilege to vote
again this is a fundamental change
openly bad-mouthing democracy and saying
out loud that voting is a privilege and
not a right
lauren kulp
is the republican candidate for congress
in washington state and he called
democracy mob rule
and that is a big talking point from
conservatives these days that the
founding fathers feared mob rule
this from the party that on january 6th
encouraged a literal mob to attempt to
rule
if you violently attack the u.s capitol
kicking in doors breaking windows
killing cops
chasing duly elected representatives out
of the building all with the intent of
overturning a lawful election and
hanging the vice president for
certifying it you know in the name of
patriotism
maybe you've lost the thread
of exactly what it is you're supposed to
be loyal to
i'm no constitutional scholar but i'm
pretty sure it doesn't say in the case
of an election loss break [ __ ] and
install your guy anyway
and
please stop imagining that you're
blowing our minds when you point out
that america is not a direct democracy
it's a republic yes duh of course even
at the time of america's founding direct
democracy where everyone who could vote
gathered in the square like an ancient
athens and put a white or a black pebble
in a big pot
yeah that was impractical
so democracy added the idea of
representatives
and with the addition of a constitution
that guided us and protected minorities
we became a republic that is
an improved type of democracy not
something apart from democracy still a
system where we vote the votes count and
the winners with reasonable restraints
are put in charge
that's the best
albeit imperfect way to do this thing
called government and we all used to get
that
but now many republicans have decided
that democracy is what's wrong with
america a lot of people drive themselves
crazy asking republicans for evidence
that biden somehow stole the election
but that's a fool's errand
in the circular logic of today's right
the evidence that the election was
stolen is that they lost
the logic goes like this we all know
america should be made great again
and one side wanted it made great again
it said so right on their hats
[Laughter]
so logically the other side wanted
america to stay bad
and there's no way jesus who loves
america would let that happen
same thing with voter fraud which has
been studied a million times all with
the same result it's negligible and
doesn't affect elections again missing
the point the evidence of voter fraud is
that sometimes democrats win
this is madness democrats and
republicans
have always certainly had their
differences taxes and
guns abortion
wearing cowboy boots with a suit
[Applause]
but neither ever really doubted that our
system of accepting electoral loss
was what made america different from so
many countries who could never get that
right it was as much as anything would
made america great
despite the fact that in a democracy
yes the people who win
sometimes get things wrong
maybe that's why churchill called
democracy the worst system of government
except for all the others
the left today is getting a lot of
things wrong
police departments gutted kids taught
crazy [ __ ] unpopular thought being
scrubbed trying to reframe america as
irredeemably racist i get the panic
but solutions short of junking democracy
can
and must handle this
what do tough guys and true patriots do
in times of panic they don't panic
but conservatives now sound creepily
like the generals in some country where
they finally experimented with democracy
for the first time and well they didn't
like it so much
i'm afraid we let the voters decide and
they [ __ ] up
next month the conservative political
action conference cpac is holding their
convention in hungary
hungary
what's the matter with kansas
well apparently it's not authoritarian
enough because the new platform from the
right is making the world safe from
democracy
you